you know you've worked with a lot of
legends man
and like i said you've you've done your
thing on a lot of people's records and
made them look crazy but who's somebody
who you were like
extra like man i really gotta bring my
[ __ ]
damn i don't know i mean
um
i love hate doing records with tech nine
ah yeah i love hate doing records with
that dude you guys got some [ __ ]
you gotta work it's like i know he feel
the same way trust me if you ask me
if you're in a lazy mode you don't want
to do a record you got to be ready you
got
you got to like miss the [ __ ] out of
wraps
i feel like tech nine always has the
biggest chip on his shoulder what he
raps like no matter what he's like
always
it's like it's just there's a chip and
it it's just
it's it's too much going on and you guys
you you were on you were on too much out
you were on the worldwide choppers with
busta rhymes yellow wolf
it was a lot of people on that record
yeah yeah i was on that
yeah like that record was
crazy like when you go back and listen
to that that was like
eight minutes straight of people just
from all over the world yeah people from
insta
from turkey on there all kinds of it was
yeah tech nines
man technique is also for a lot of
artists if
you want to come up go watch the
technology concert so you can figure out
how to perform too because that
[ __ ] is a beast live
oh yeah so who are you you got another
guy um it's probably a bunch of them
but uh i can't think of any right now
that uh let me see who
pops right in my head of course
jay of course jay yeah um
hmm popping
popping tags was one man i gotta do this
record with this person and i was like
damn
i wouldn't say s uh worried or scared
but but
probably uh my thought process on how i
was gonna come with my delivery or
what to do with this particular person
you know sort of
like damn this such a such oh this is
so-and-so right
you know so like mariah
somebody like that you know yeah like
damn
you know but like like another rapper or
something like that it's probably
somebody i just can't think of
anybody right now besides tech
technologies
that's the one thing and probably buster
buster yeah
it's the work you got to put some damn
work in and you're going to feel like
all that sometimes
for sure